The Paramount Network series "Yellowstone"
has, over the course of its four seasons,
become one of its most popular hits. So
fans of the series were naturally excited to
learn that a prequel had been greenlit by the
network, with "Yellowstone" co-creator Taylor
Sheridan serving as the sole creator this time
around, marking his second collaboration with
the streaming service Paramount+, after
the crime drama "Mayor of Kingstown."
The show, titled "1883," follows
the ancestors of the Dutton family,
who are the focus of "Yellowstone," and
stars Sam Elliott, Billy Bob Thornton,
LaMonica Garrett, Tim McGraw, and Faith Hill.
Their characters journey from Texas to Montana,
coming across all kinds of treacherous threats,
to lay claim to what would eventually become the
Dutton Ranch. Fans of "Yellowstone" know all too
well the kinds of headaches that accompany owning
a piece of property that large in the modern era,
and if the modern-day Duttons
thought they had it bad,
James and Margaret Dutton are about to
show the world how much worse it can get.
There have been numerous reasons for fans to get
excited, from the time period to the pedigree of
creator Taylor Sheridan. However, above all else,
this show has one of the most stellar casts in
any modern-day drama, especially when it comes to
the casting of real-life couple McGraw and Hill.
In a recent interview, McGraw
revealed that the cast of the
show could have looked quite different
if a certain stipulation hadn't been met.
This is the one condition under which
McGraw agreed to star in "1883."
Tim McGraw is country music royalty,
with Faith Hill as his queen.
The two have been married since 1996
and have three children together,
so they have one of the longest-running
marriages in the entertainment industry, by far.
While the two have shared the stage plenty
of times in the past, they've surprisingly
never acted together despite both of them
having rather extensive filmographies.
In an interview with the YouTube channel DC
Film Girl, Tim McGraw was asked about the
fact that both he and his wife Faith Hill are
in the series, with the interviewer wondering
if that was part of the stipulation for
him doing the show in the first place.
McGraw replied that the end result was the same,
but the route was different. McGraw clarified,
"We had done a flashback scene or
two for 'Yellowstone's' last season,
and that was how this whole idea came about of
doing the prequel series. And so, once we had done
the flashback sequence, we were sort of married
to each other, so to speak, as it were anyway."
The country music superstar added that having his
wife on the show was part of the deal, saying,
"[W]hen it came time to do this show, we
were definitely going to do it together,
period. We loved the writing so much, and there
was no way we were going to do it separately.
But I think they were kind
of stuck with us anyway."
Tim McGraw and Faith Hill
are both country megastars,
so it's a big deal for them
to star in "1883" together.
Undoubtedly, other projects must have come along
over the years with various movies and TV shows
wanting the power couple to hop aboard. What
about "1883" was different from all of those?
In a separate interview with DC Film Girl, the
host had a chance to speak with Faith Hill,
and she asks what made her want to play Margaret
Dutton. Hill said that it was the writing.
Taylor Sheridan does the bulk of the
writing on both "Yellowstone" and "1883,"
and he has numerous other Westerns
and neo-Westerns to his name.
He's one of the hottest writers in Hollywood
right now, so it makes sense McGraw and
Hill would want to hitch their wagon,
metaphorically speaking, to the artist.
Hill goes on to elaborate,
"It's one of the best things
I've ever read. Truthfully,
and yeah, that was really it. It was
the writing, the story of this family."
It'll be interesting to see how the tale of
James and Margaret influences the modern-day
story of "Yellowstone." But for now, you can
see how McGraw and Hill's real-life relationship
translates on-screen when the first season
of "1883" continues on Sundays on Paramount+.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about the
world of "Yellowstone" are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.